I did okay is that what you want to eat
we're fine we're fine take it easy
when you meddle in someone's personal
life it's just so rewarding
oh God
what's up
[Laughter]
everybody smile away
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm waiting on my arm Andy
I'm holding the dog he's peeing he's now
peeing and putting him down no Ronnie
only has three legs
so it just goes on under here like this
that's right
oh gosh yeah you never get used to that
hey just wanted to check in see how
you're doing I am so great he's great
we're all great 12 dogs
this is my life now I'm a dog nurse are
you sure you should be working I mean
you should be resting and getting fluids
and and cold compresses and greasy Foods
that's for a hangover
yeah of course I'm so goofed up right
now I am so jet-lagged I took a sleeping
pill on the plane and then I changed my
mind so I took this thing called zap
vigil which apparently is what Israeli
fighter pilots use to stay awake so
right now it looks like I'm talking to a
giant crab stay away from me crab
just kidding I know it's Anne whenever
Leslie asked me for the Latin names of
any of our plants I just gave her the
names of rappers are those over there uh
those are some Diddy's there's some bone
thugs-n-harmoniums right here growing
beautifully those ludicrouses are coming
in great look someone planted something
new what's this
what do you think carrots that's true we
have a garden passed on our hands
maybe some kind of spice yeah you know
Leslie the best way to figure out what
kind of spice that is is roll it up into
a joint and smoke it
let's just relax smoke another Jay and
all calm down another by the way it's
ridiculous that pot is illegal it grows
in the ground I've planted marijuana and
Community Gardens all over the city and
hasn't hurt anyone you know I'll tell
you what honey here's the deal you get
fired I'll quit we'll leave together I'm
serious move to a new city change our
names burn our fingertips off with acid
swap faces what if we have to okay
that's good on places to live let's go
back to dream jobs we had to start a new
life I have detective FBI agent
policeman CIAA agent so we need more for
you let's go it's fun I'm trying to help
you take your mind off of this horrible
mistake you made deleting all these
files probably the worst thing that ever
happened in parks and rec history it
will certainly get fired and I'm trying
to help a mosaic portrait of each of you
made from the Crush of your favorite
diet soda
flies five thousand word essay of why
you're all so awesome thank you so much
I need it I got a really bad case of
shoe shine head today Andy recently
diagnosed himself with what he calls
shoeshine head
it's when you shine too many shoes and
the fumes create a thunderstorm in your
brain
cures include coffee cheeseburgers
and napping on the floor
Leslie nope hey Chris
wow is that new jogging shirt it is
it's an experimental fabric called
bumbleflex it's made out of synthetic
beeswings it's cool anyway you're not
supposed to be here you're suspended I
totally understand that I'm just going
to take my flash drive and I'll do some
work from home and
oh you're specifically prohibited from
doing your job oh I'm not gonna do my
job I'm just gonna oversee the
department and check in on the parks and
attend any meetings that are required of
the deputy director honestly go home and
give me the flash drive
this is a nasal spray
give me the flash drive give me the
nails bro
on three one two two three
okay good now in two weeks
lastly no I am much faster than you I
have bubble flex I absolutely think that
we should keep campaigning the worst
possible thing we could do would be to
stop because the campaign stops we all
stop and stopping is certain death who
went to Panini anyone everyone I'm gonna
say everyone all right
hello hi I'm Leslie Knope I called a
little while ago
you have a lot of nerve showing your
face here
excuse me you have overdue book fees
totaling three dollars Missy
that's so typical I should have known
you'd use a low blow dirty pool BS move
like that that's why everybody hates the
library here you know what here's your
three dollars and I'll see you in hell
oh my gosh I mean you did have three
dollars worth of fines but I cleared
them
we government gals have to watch each
other's backs right
I know this is a trap but I don't know
how can't stand this government shutdown
I can't stand this budget crisis but
what I can't stand is they're canceling
Friday spaghetti you know everything
what should I do about this I don't know
Leslie why don't you see a movie or go
shopping wait a minute what are you
doing what's happening
um
you know they offer me a buyout and I
took it
and so now I work for Norton
Construction
sorry I know I shouldn't have done that
it's okay what the hell Ron
you're building your stupid building on
the Block next to Pawnee Commons the
park that I built from scratch out of a
pit this building is going to ruin the
views you jerk and you're gonna tear all
the houses down yes and live there Ron
Anne's old house that's my best friend's
old house that was the house where I put
on my wedding dress the night I got
married that is the house where April
and Andy met for the first time that is
the house where Ann gave me my first
ever smokey eye look she hasn't lived
there for five years that's not the
point this building is a monstrosity and
what's it called Morning Star oh dear we
live at the Morning Star the two Posh
and hibbly fibbly-gibly the world needs
apartment buildings the park you built
is nice and people want to live next to
it they get you one other present to
take your mind off all this you are the
sweetest man in the world where is it
well
it's not here we have to go get it
[Music]
in times of stress or moments of
transition sometimes it can feel like
the whole world is closing in on you
when that happens you
close your eyes take a deep breath
listen to the people who love you when I
give you advice
[Music]
you never had any kids right Leslie
hello
you've got a great oven okay
we've got ample room in there honestly
if you wanted to you could go triplets
right off the bat Leslie you got a big
industrial sized oven
now Ben wants me to slow down but I had
this huge project coming up and
some changes but you're a healthy gal
right Leslie there is no reason for you
not to be yourself I win did wasn't a
competition all right let's see what's
going down in babytown
there's your healthy baby oh wow
wow oh and there's another one the baby
has two bodies twins
Ben we're having twins
no you're not because look who's hiding
over here
's a fourth I'm so sorry no it's a
little Fleck of cream cheese on the
screen
just triplets